hey everyone I'm Chris osaki creative
director of Forza Motorsport and I'm
joined by Tyler Hennessey talented
developer on our team who'll be driving
the demo today for us everything you see
today is production code running on an
Xbox series X and all of the gameplay
you'll see is at 4K 60 with true gen 9
graphics
Forza as a franchise has always been
about falling in love with cars
Forza Motorsport has been doing that
through the thrill and intensity of
competition
today you'll get to see our bold new
take on falling in love with cars that's
comprised of three major themes
First theme is about getting to know a
car finding its limits and building that
level of car mastery
the second is about taking that car and
building it into the track Dominator
that you've always wanted
and finally it's about taking that car
competing with it and winning with it on
the track
is the new Forza Motorsport Loop level
build Dominate and there's no better way
to check out this new level build
dominate Loop than in our all new career
mode the builders cup
the builders cup has a new rhythm of
racing that includes an open Practice A
new challenge the grid system and of
course a featured race
now you'll be seeing all of that today
as well as our car progression systems
and of course our carb building
so let's Dive In
so this is the Builder's cup
this career mode is always fresh and
surprising
new cars are revealed and released by
manufacturers all the time
we wanted our career mode to reflect
this ever-changing landscape of cars
you can see here there's a bunch of new
icons on some of these racing series so
for the first time in Forza Motorsport
new cars and tracks will be released
directly into this career
[Music]
the Builder's cup will shift change and
evolve with all of this new content
behind each of these cool posters is a
racing series where you'll get to take a
single car and level it build it and
dominate your way to Victory
the cars in each series have exciting
Automotive stories that we want you to
experience and is your gateway to find
cars to fall in love with
this is the built for sports series it's
made up of modern sports car
masterpieces like the new Supra as you
can see
uh the Porsche Cayman GTS or the new
Nissan Z
and today we're going to be jumping in
with a new Z for our look at the
builders cup
now each of these Series has a cool
intro that highlights their Automotive
story and might just give you that
reason to pick one and maybe fall in
love with it so let's check it out
every year manufacturers set out to
build a car of the moment
that defines who they are
cars that are Nimble well engineered
with a futuristic design aesthetic
not Exclusive Automotive fantasies
desirable
attainable
each offering a welcome invitation for a
motivated hard driving Enthusiast to get
in buckle up and then Define who they
are at the absolute limit on the
racetrack
thank you
so the builders cup has a new rhythm of
racing
every event in the Builder's cup
features an open practice session
in open practice is where you put the
work in to find the limits of your car
and it's never been more fun engaging or
rewarding to just drive your car and
push it to its limits
after the final tight hairpin turned 16
anyway
accelerate onto the long straight where
you'll be able to catch your competition
so I like to think that for a
relationship with your car is forged at
speed at the limit
we've created a bunch of new systems
that help you find that limit build that
relationship and reward you for it
I'm gonna let Tyler drive for a little
bit here so you can kind of see the the
4K 60 visuals and all of our remastered
audio
[Music]
what you're seeing here
is our new car Mastery system
Each corner is now a moment-to-moment
objective where you get to see how fast
you are through them
how close you are to the Limit with your
car
each time you go through a given corner
it will compare you against your best
time through it and it helps you master
your car
this also gives car XP and you can see
that in the top right here your car is
now gaining XP corner by corner and
leveling up in real time
you're getting faster you're
understanding the car's limits and your
car is leveling up and growing with you
your relationship with your car is
forged at speed
this is the core of our car progression
and it's now the heartbeat of our game
and I like to think of it as a carpi g
our new track Dynamics can always shift
and change and for the first time we
have fully Dynamic time of day and
weather on every track
no two laps ever look or play the same
so Tyler's gonna pull off on the side of
the road here we're going to take a look
at our time of day and weather settings
these Dynamics challenge you to mask
your car hour by hour dry or wet this
makes open practice that much more
valuable to get you ready to take on the
competition during the race
so let's end practice and move into the
next beat into the Builder's cup which
is challenge the grid
this is all new
and I'm really excited about this
challenge the grid is all about dialing
in the racing challenge that you want
and it's never been more fun or engaging
all of the challenge options are here at
your fingertips and they all affect your
payout
so you can actually choose where you
want to begin or start the race
and you can also change up the AI
difficulty racing rules and damage
settings if you like and all of that can
change your payout
challenge the grid lets you choose the
exact risk reward balance that you want
in the race
so let's jump into the featured race
looks like we're starting mid-pack here
so you've gotten to know the car track
combo in open practice
you feel good about the gameplay balance
that you've dialed in with challenge the
grid and now it's time to battle it out
on the track with the rest of the field
to see who comes out on top
so you're seeing here is a field of
drivatars populated with your friends
their cars and their deliveries
all of this is constantly updating with
their latest creations and
customizations
so even when you're racing in Builders
cup you're connected to your friends
racing has never been better with our
overhauled physics and AI
the AI drivatar technology has big
advancements
our new machine learning powered AI is
as fast as the fastest real drivers
without any cheats or hacks to keep them
competitive
without these cheats the racing has
never been so immersive you can trust
that anytime you're pulling them in a
straight you're actually out driving
them
[Music]
physics have big advancements as well
we have an entirely new tire model that
features a 48x jump infidelity
we've also rebuilt a suspension weight
and arrow modeling
the simulation has never been more
accurate and the cars feel incredible to
drive
you can see some of the tight racing
here is all thanks to all of the new AI
improvements
foreign
[Music]
so I know the racing is exciting
and as much as I'd like to watch this we
only have a short time here so
um
let's go ahead and finish up the race
so here are the race results where you
get to see your Series points that lead
into the overall trophy for the series
but you also get to see how you're doing
in the overall built for sport racing
series you get your driver XP here your
credits pay out and your car XP
after every event in the builders cup
you have a chance to build up your car
and continue in your journey with it and
you can see here we've just unlocked a
number of upgrades that you can go and
install in your car
so let's actually go and check out our
new car building screen
ours in the new Forza Motorsport are
built not bought
your bond with your car is earned it's
the work you've put in to find its
limits
as your car levels up it gains car
points and unlocks upgrades
here up in the top right you can see
your car points and that's the resource
that's used to install any of the
upgrades if you unlocked
car points are like skill or Talent
points in other games you can allocate
them to install a part but here's the
thing you aren't locked into any of
those choices at any time
you can easily uninstall a part and
regain those car points so you can use
those points elsewhere
it's like being able to endlessly
respect a character
this gives the player a great amount of
agency and building experimentation
also since you aren't spending credits
on upgrades the built not bot system
frees you from having to decide between
say buying a cool new car or upgrading
your current car
now with these upgrades installed we can
go to the next event and see how this
car build feels on the next track and
get ready to dominate
and that's a single event in the
builders cup
so you've got to see our open practice
where you find the limits of your car
and level it up
A new challenge the grid feature where
you can dial in the racing challenge
that you want
and of course our feature race where the
racing has never been better
and finally our car building where your
car is built not bought
that's the new Forza Motorsport Loop
level
build
dominate
and the builders cup is just a small
part of this big game
we have an all new featured multiplayer
mode Rivals time attack and of course
free play all make the return to the
game
and we'll be diving into the details of
these other modes in the months to come
so stay tuned the new era of Forza
Motorsport begins on October 10th
and we can't wait for you to get your
hands on it thanks everyone
[Music]